you'll see you're making us feel like
shame because you're wearing pants -
just team up but I couldn't I'm with
Mike yeah that's a tactic that's what
that is yeah that's a tactic yeah what
kind of what do you mean it's a tactic
they trying to like come on man show us
your dick this is how you show everyone
you dick you get together with five of
your buddies and you all are real
comfortable with seeing each other's
dicks right we're gonna get to some
Mikey's dick how you gonna do that we're
gonna shame them I'm gonna shame them in
and showing us his dick and we're gonna
take our dicks out we're gonna walk into
that steam room I'm just gonna let you
nuts hang want to see what the fuck were
you do when you but take your goddamn
pants off
and they'll be like Oh Roy Jesus why
does everyone wanna see my keys so bad
because my key probably is a little dick
I felt like everybody thinks I have a
small one because I got my pants but
that's not it um purely for research
purposes I was on line the other night
googling into dick surgery dick
enlargement surgery it was after that
billionaire guy actually died what yeah
he was a diamond dealer he was in his
60s and I want to say was I don't know
he's in Europe or somewhere anyway
homeboy got some dick surgery plans died
on the operating table
oh wow I didn't even know they're doing
that she surgery yeah you don't you
don't let my grandmother had a saying
don't let anyone mess with your eyes or
your dick yeah there it is he goes the
the gentleman had been high where you
going
he had a heart attack in the middle of
the procedure which isn't FDA approved
then says is it safe
dunt dunt uh I think anytime you go
under it's not 100% safe anytime yeah
putting you wondering cutting you open I
went under for the first time last month
it was anesthetic deaths those from the
anesthetic that's what I'm saying yeah
they put you under man you could fucking
die I know I was worried about and he's
an older fella I think that guy was in
his 60s it includes surgical lengthening
which in-house cutting a ligament
at the base of the penis a key or filler
injections I'll go with filler let's see
what you do with filler first and if I'm
gonna cut my dick later to use a filler
like that on foam you spray into the
insulation and they come through the
asshole
what is this implant for men ah turbo Oh
hold on hold on you're gonna shove
plastic and your dick is that what that
guy has yeah like a sling little stop
stop stop stop stop stop squirting no
look at this thing you have you could
pick your size it's a sleeve it's like a
sleeve you didn't show that dick on TV
not work they they can stick the extra
long like what if you like it oh my god
oh my god this is so bad looks like
animation it looks like a little piece
of gutter a small incision just above
the base of the penis where your pubes
are yeah and then okay then they slide
it down into your shaft I got I got one
word for everybody really what is it
infection
ah what a dick infection oh my god one
word for you
popular I think that works implant
secure now a wooden sutures which are
generally not detectable by a patient or
whatever ah so you have like this sleeve
inside the skin I'll tell you what's
going on now though and porn this is
some real shit they they have they have
GMO which takes an hour
there's GMO dicks now what sister way
bigger I was watching that
an old porn film with John Holmes when
we were kids yeah John Holmes is the guy
with the biggest dick yeah John Holmes
has a regular dick compared to porn
stars for real especially and this
sounds racist black guys well of course
races in the right direction though yes
the other day that I was like that can't
be real that literally can't be real
his dick was so big it was preposterous
he probably had an 18 inch dick 18 18
inch deck it was so and it was it's
thick around as your fucking wrist
is ridiculous there was a girl and a
suck on it I was like see I don't think
the girls want that this girl's like
this I mean I don't know maybe the girl
was 50 pounds I don't think so I mean if
she was he still had a 12-inch dick I'm
like gigantic it was so ridiculously big
that as I was watching this film was
like okay what's happened over the last
20-30 years with porn that we've evolved
today yeah he just got a lot of guys out
of in the recruitment yeah I guess right
like the perception of what a dick was
from like yeah I hear them saying like
there's this implant that may or may not
work that we just watch that little
commercial for and it's brutal yeah but
outside of that yeah what would cause
like a girl if girls wanted bigger boobs
they'd get a boob job
yeah that's common yeah we're used to
that but guys with giant dicks I don't
think they're getting operations I think
these are just is just a crop of dudes
with giant you know a new class of guys
the bigs are so big this recruit I'm in
the fuck we've had a real great draft
this year it's different it's like
people the big dick dudes from like the
1970s and 80s they had kids with people
who ate a lot of vitamin maybe it was an
optical illusion because we had more
pubes back then no it was coming out of
the car you didn't see half a no no no
no no no this guy was these guys are
masters guy had a snake yeah it was it
was a fat snake that you would like
capture in the Everglades this is why I
kept my pants on at the banya I didn't
want people yeah intimidate if you got a
dick like that you just swing that thing
anywhere you want whatever you want it
who cares who cares
well anyway and I sure this black white
dudes that have giant dick Stooges
there's a couple not seeing them I'm not
seeing them at the same with the season
I'm just being honest the limited amount
of research that I've done there's a
there's a difference I mean yeah I think
what your defense mechanism was right
like rightly to say yeah women don't
want that they don't want that giant
dick that hurts them every time oh I get
it bro come on I know where you come
I want my ladies to be happy not upset
some girls wanna be upset that guy by
the way
billionaire mm-hmm in his 60s why are
you even thinking about its bored why
are you even he's bored
isn't that amazing but if you've got
that much money stop and think about
that you're in your sixties you got that
much money yeah you have billions of
dollars and how much time do you have
left and what do you do with your money
and what do you do with your time
you know the good dudes probably fucking
bored of shit Oh has it come down to sex
why not get a hobby
you're so old timing look at this each
injection of hyaluronic acid fillers
cost between two hundred fifteen seven
hundred fifty dollars and the ads girth
row said person patients usually begin
with about ten ten injections injection
filler injections whoo Jesus Christ it's
not good the patient could have given
him general anesthesia which may
exacerbate a pre-existing heart
conditions
oh Jesus Christ got heart he had a heart
condition this guy yeah see they live it
you know what
hold on put that back on it says if
you're getting general anesthesia and
you have an underlying malady in your
heart you will unmask that and it will
show itself Jesus people are so bored
so all this money and it just makes you
more bored ultimately yeah
ridiculous I think people just get on a
path right and what is the Matt the path
is to to acquire success yeah when
you're doing something like selling
diamonds you know congratulations for
making a lot of money people like to buy
diamonds but what are you doing what are
you doing those diamonds and you're
buying diamonds you're selling diamonds
you're buying diamond and you're getting
older and you're like oh my god I'm at
the end of the ride what am i doing what
was this right about yeah fuck it and
why would be going in we're gonna take
anesthesia I'm gonna get a dick fix but
because he was just essentially moving
money around he wasn't making something
is you think that's it that there was no
worth to what he was doing I think just
like he wasn't being satisfied mentally
with his
job with his work with his life yeah I
think this is probably a lot of people
in his sort of position